Your task in this problem is to write a regular polygon creator. A regular
polygon is one that has equal angles and equal length sides. When you create the
polygon, sucessive points will be counter clockwise. Your job is to form the
minimum number of traingles that triangulates this surface. Your draw function
is called polygon draw function in the code. It takes as an input the number of
sides desired. I'll provide you the basic trigonometry function for generating
the polygons points. This code the produces x and y creates the polygons
vertices. For example when the loop variable point is at 0, the 2D point at x
and y is going to be the point 0,1. Your job is to save the vertices, then use
these vertices in a loop that generates the faces for the polygon. Here's what
your aiming for, a regular polygon centered around the origin.